If you don't say it, you won't understand Even if you do, you
won't get it
So
you should say the answer
Even if you know that
you'll regret your choice, I've started to hate your way of
thinking
You were the one who said
no I don't really know what you're thinking I'm
going to break down because of that
It's just what I used to be No
I
like this club
[Music]
[Applause]
Help me  Well, I
'm thinking about it properly I'm
suffering
Red Day
Aura is in
Hikigaya Ward
[Music]
I don't have any requests from you
Well,
I
wonder if you'll listen to my request.
There is no place
My youth romantic comedy is wrong after all
Season 3
production decision
[Music]
[Applause]
me